well let's take a look then at the terms
of the New Windsor framework there will
be a twin Lane system for Customs the
Green Lane will allow trusted traders to
send goods from Great Britain into
Northern Ireland without checks
meanwhile Goods destined for Ireland and
the EU single Market will go through the
red lane vat rates and state aid policy
will be set by Westminster rather than
by Brussels
and the Prime Minister also announced
what he called the Stormont break
allowing the Northern Ireland assembly
to prevent EU laws applying but the
European commission says the European
court of justice will retain the final
say on single Market issues a
significant sticking point for Tory
euroskeptics and the dup
well our Deputy political editor Sam
Coates has been pouring over the 27
pages of the agreement let's hear now
from his assessment Sam
27 Pages 13
000 words now it's a deal that Boris
Johnson Liz trust or even Theresa May
could not strike so what's in it well
what is clear is that this negotiation
is a big deal the Windsor framework work
fundamentally amends the texts and
provisions of the original protocol
something Brussels always said they
would never do
and it takes steps to address some of
the real tensions that the original deal
was causing right now businesses face a
stack of paperwork to get their goods
from Britain to Northern Ireland this
jail does change that in the future if
you're sending British manufactured
items to Northern Ireland you're going
to be using the Green Lane so that good
being sold in Northern Ireland will be
freed of unnecessary paperwork only
Goods going on to the EU will need
processes and requirements now that's
code for forms and checks
has solved what are the key anomalies of
brexit and that's that Brussels not
Westminster had powers over some tax
rates in Northern Ireland much to his
irritation when he was Chancellor now in
future Northern Ireland will benefit
from the same vat and alcohol taxes as
apply in the rest of the United Kingdom
and the deal amends the legal texts of
the treaty to do so
now here is the crucial question that
dup unionists and brexit conservatives
have been worrying about how to stop
rules made in Brussels applying to good
signals in Ireland when they don't have
to apply in the rest of the United
Kingdom enter the new Stormont break
it's a new tool which the Prime Minister
says has the power to veto the
application of new Brussels rules and
the eu's legal enforcement to Northern
Ireland permanently now there are some
exceptions some areas are exempt from it
and it can't be used on trivial issues
but the deal says any veto would be
permanent and can only be undone if the
UK and the EU agree jointly so where
next Tory MPS are mulling their response
lots of eyes on Boris Johnson the
document says that Richie sunac is going
to scrap his predecessor says alternate
plan a new law to unilaterally rip up
the deal without consulting Brussels
Johnson told Sky News last week it was
the best way for words but Rishi sunak
believes doing deals is the Better Way
Forward he now hopes a stronger
relationship with the EU could even mean
an agreement with France to sort out
boats crossing the channel he needs to
show his brexit deal has lots of
possible advantages